build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
Creations from Everyday People this is
bdp building William Olsen builds
incredible Ghostbuster proton backpack
replicas they're made from metal wood
and plastic to the exact dimensions of
the original packs and feature full
workking lights and
sounds hackers at MIT turned a building
on campus into a playable game of Tetris
the hack had been originally conceived
in 1995 because the layout of the
building's Windows lent itself to Tetris
and it was just recently pulled off
without School permission using an
impressive array of colors in the
windows the hmof is a secret Treehouse
built on Crown Land in Canada Joel Allen
built the egg shaped Treehouse somewhere
near Whistler British Columbia and it's
in danger of being taken down check out
the website for more information if you
want to make your own puzzle out of an
apple check out this video find the link
below to watch the whole thing just
don't cut your hand off TR Australian
artist George Evangelista makes detailed
fan art paintings of Pop Culture
characters including Lio chitara and
panro from ThunderCats and some choice
friends and foes from Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles also anyone who recognizes
this dude gets 500 imaginary Vsauce
points for one of a kind sand paintings
there's the work of Joe mangram the New
York artist creates these colorful
pieces armed with just handfuls of sand
and he's particularly fond of this
medium because of its momentary nature
being Swept Away sometime after
completion and now for some pieces from
light Gray's Pokemon Battle Royale
[Music]
exhibition
finally video games versus real life
plunks famous Retro Gaming characters in
real life photographs including E Honda
link and a base jumping leming play
Diego sto's music from nature was
created in real time using instruments
provided by Mother
[Music]
Nature Liam Readington created GB City a
pixel animation with music from Phantom
[Music]
men this Beatles mashup combines
instrument parts from different songs
into one seamless experience find the
link below and watch with annotations
enabled to see which parts are from
which
[Music]
songs finally I Robot Dance Revolution
is a pop and lock Showdown featuring
Maris
[Music]
Scott submit your own bdps as a personal
message here on YouTube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucegaming and as always
thanks for
[Music]
watching
all the girls get
down all my dos get
up all the get
down all my get
up
[Music]